it was uh brought to my attention
recently I was at the gym
um you know warming up I'm on a
treadmill
there's this lady that comes she's on
the phone she's got those earbuds and
she's just you know they're talking so
she's on the the treadmill yapping away
and she's oh girl have you seen this new
series on Netflix and Jeffrey Dahmer and
uh let's just like I'm just like picking
up on these like sound bites and I
remembered a few tricks that I've dated
in the past that were absurdly obsessed
with
um series documentaries and TV shows
around either uh serial killers prison
shows and this sort of stuff and there's
this concept called hybristophilia
I don't know if you guys have heard it
but I think we should probably start
with defining what this unusual
attraction and it's generally a sexual
attraction believe it or not is the
serial killers
um
throughout history it's it's not
something that's a brand new phenomenon
in the last few years or anything like
that it's been going on for a long time
and there's some reasons behind it let
me pull up the Wiki page here and I
guess we'll start with that and by the
way make sure if you are watching this
on the internets do me a solid let me
grab the link over here head on over to
YouTube and click that link and watch
over there that's where I'll be dropping
the join link will be taking some
call-ins tonight some q and A's open to
everybody and anybody bring your
questions to the table once we've done
this uh intro bit on women's addiction
to
criminals is the only way to put it
um so let me share my screen here
a window tab
so
hybristophilia is the technical
definition for it let's see if we can
make this a little bit bigger so you
guys can see this as well
um yes uh
all right it is a sexual interest and
attraction in Those who commit crimes a
paraphilia in which
sexual arousal of
even talk about attainment of orgasm are
responsive to and contingent upon being
with a partner known to have committed a
crime the term is derived from the Greek
word huberson I think I'm pronouncing
that correctly meaning to commit an out
an outrage against someone
uh skip the definition part in popular
culture this phenomenon is also known as
a Bonnie and Clyde syndrome
so uh many whole Pro high profile
criminals particularly those that have
committed atrocious crimes receive fan
mail I've got some clips and some
articles to share with you talking about
that a little bit in prison and that is
sometimes uh Amorous or sexual
presumably as a result of the phenomenon
in some cases admirers of these
criminals have gone on to marry the
object of their affection in prison
uh we'll skip the terminology let's go
into causes over here
some speculations have been offered as
to the causes of hybristophilia for
instance uh Catherine ramsland who's a
professor of forensic psychology at
Desales University mentions that some of
the women in particular who have married
or dated male serial killers have
offered the following reasons now
there's some Evo psych reasons in here
we're going to get into in a second
which is kind of sick and disgusting at
the same time but it just it just goes
to show you you know what human nature
is all about I read a few articles today
on this topic and they all summarize
basically the same thing so I think this
is probably the best place to start
um so this researcher Catherine says low
self-esteem and the lack of a father
figure so these are the contributing
factors for women's uh interests and
attraction to these criminal males
um low self-esteem lack of father figure
some believe they can change a man as
cruel and Powerful as a serial killer
so it's like you know when guys play
Captain Save A Hoe I guess women like to
play Captain Save a criminal others see
the little boy in that killer once was
and seek to nurture him a few hoped and
shared in the media Spotlight uh to get
a book or movie deal so this is the
admission of some of these admirers then
there's a notion of the perfect
boyfriend she knows where he is at all
times she knows he's thinking about her
while she can claim that someone loves
her she does not have to endure
day-to-day issues involved in most
relationships there's no laundry to do
no cooking to do for him no
accountability to him and can keep a
fantasy charge now I think this is just
a load of [ __ ] this is you know
we've said this many times on the show
like don't believe what women say watch
what they do and watch the choices that
lead up to what they're doing this is
all a lot of blah blah blah a lot of
opinions
um
others have offered reasons along the
lines of some mental health experts have
compared infatuation with Killers to
extreme forward of fanaticism they view
such women as insecure females who
cannot find love normal ways as love
avoidant females who seek romantic
relationships that cannot be consummated
there's some video footage which I'm
going to show you soon with some of
these women that are fascinated with
these killers and they're not completely
out there like they're not gross okay so
it's not like they can't get guys out in
the real world so this is where I think
it really boils down to because for me
whenever I come across something that's
just Bonkers like just out there I like
to go to Evo psych it's if you know
there's got to be some research out
there that's that's that's studied a
paper done something on this and I think
this last paragraph here distills it
perfectly so this psychologist Leon
Seltzer has offered explanations for the
phenomenon of male serial killers
attracting female sex partners based on
evolutionary psychology uh serial
killers in his view are cases of alpha
males that tend to attract women this is
because such alpha males were good at
protecting women and their offspring
report according to evolutionary history
he says women today May consciously
realize that it is unwise to date a
serial killer but they are nevertheless
attracted to them he stated as a
therapist have encountered many women
who have bemoaned their vulnerability
towards dominant men who cautiously they
recognize we're all wrong for them
as evidence of women's fantasy
preferences for dominant men he refers
to a book uh it's titled a billion
Wicked thoughts I actually just
downloaded this I want to listen to it
and the subtitle is what the world's
largest experiment reveals about human
desire author's name is ogi agus
interesting name
um Seltzer discusses agus and gadams I
want to say God gdam's argument this
fantasy is dominant plot of most erotic
romantic books blah blah blah now
I came across
some some footage as well and some other
you know psych papers and one of the
things that they also talked about was
that
women throughout history have mates
selected for strong competent men
okay and guys that are strong are going
to be able to defeat
scary animals saber-toothed tigers the
bad guys the warring tribes that sort of
thing so it would make sense that women
would have an attraction to guys that
have been able to display
some would call dominance others would
call cowardness depending on the crimes
they committed but clearly demonstrate
that they have the competence to take
life okay I'm not saying that's right or
wrong that's that's just what they're
attracted to so again you know I've said
this for a while women like to choose
winners you know people that are
competent in worldly Affairs again this
is one really bizarre way that they find
like these types of people attractive
but nonetheless
you've got to look at their behavior
like you know this is what's happening
so let me grab my headphones here
because there's a couple of uh audio
clips that I'm going to play in a second
uh actually let me share this
Reddit here so if you guys have read my
book uh the unplugged Alpha I talked in
one of the chapters about
um this kid Nicholas Cruz that uh went
on a shooting spree in Parkland uh let
me share this back to the Stream
so this is a Reddit post that I found
and I just started Googling stuff like
um you know why do women love uh
murderers why do women love uh you know
Nicholas Cruz or Ted Bundy or you know
like all these names out there so this
kid uh just kind of quickly recap
incel kid that wanted to be with uh
women women didn't reciprocate their
interest in him he was pissed off was
never raised by
um a father he didn't have a father in a
household in fact he was he was The
Offspring of a drunk uh mom who gave him
up for adoption
who had another kid also while going
through her drinking issues and stuff
gave that other kid up for adoption both
these two kids were adopted by a
two-parent household they couldn't have
kids the father died when both the kids
were very very young so this kid
Nicholas was raised by a single mother
adopted single mother
anyway he goes on a shooting spree kills
a bunch of other kids and uh you know is
convicted so you can you know look up
his name I also talk about him in the
book so some of this might be a little
bit fresher to some other people that
have seen my content
so this woman says I have a crush on
Nicholas Clues Cruz he got locked away
and lost it all Nicholas Cruz yes the
Parkland shooter I find him so
attractive ASF let me just remove this
out so I can give you a visual so you
know what he looks like uh
this is this is the dude that she finds
attractive ASF
this geek over here okay
this is him in the courtroom this is the
guy that she's got the hots for
so just just to sort of frame it for you
uh let me go back to the Reddit post
uh I find him attractive ASF Parkland
happened when I was in high school
cruises about four years older than me
back then I saw a picture of Nick my
teacher had him up on the screen and my
heart skipped beats I thought he was
really cute and now I've been watching
his trial lately and I didn't know
whether I wanted him to get sentenced to
death because getting Neils is so much
better than deteriorating and suffering
itself for decades to be honest but I
don't want him to die either I hope I
get to see him in another life if it
exists that picture of of him in his
ROTC uniform
what is ROTC I'm assuming that's like a
jail uniform or something
ROTC Correction Facility reserves
reserves Officers Training corpse
I don't even know what that is I'm
Canadian obviously so bear with me on
stuff like this
okay so she sees a picture of him in an
rot's uniform made me so wet NGL that
stands for not gonna lie I have dreams
about him pretty much every night I love
his eyes his smile his awkwardness just
everything about him but I know I can
never be with him at least not in this
life I know it's pretty effed up I guess
but I don't care I love him and I always
will is there something wrong with me
what's making me feel this way if
there's a God why he made me so hot for
shooters
hahaha
uh this dude's like urgent get help talk
to a psychiatrist she goes I don't know
I already have a therapist I talked to
about it and she told me it's fine
of course anyway uh but I've seen this
guy but I've never seen a guy as hot as
Cruz again keep in mind this is the same
dude that I just showed you okay the
skinny geek that went on a shooting
spree uh I fantasize about being his
prison girlfriend all the time she
understands it's hybristophilia or
whatever it's called
uh
she goes on to say over here honestly he
probably would have shot me I don't
really care I think that's what that
stands for idrc uh but I heard he did
spare a few people that day plus he had
a bad life as well I just wish I could
have saved him oh well so there's that
saved him part right oh well I I will
say I kind of wish she got the death
sentence because it's easier to go out
and whatever like there's no guys out
there that have a
ffinity like guys have some weird kind
of addictions and attractions like I've
I've talked to guys that have like foot
fetishes and I'm like why you know
that's that's weird whatever but I've
never heard of a guy or or groups of
guys that fantasize or romanticize for
female criminals the way that women
fantasize and romanticize for male
criminals it just doesn't exist it's
it's a phenomenon that only exists with
women directing their love and attention
towards these guys and again you know
I've we've postulated some of the evil
psych reasons there for it
um here's a few other clips that I want
to share with you guys so I'm just going
to throw these on so I can hear it with
you
uh
uh let me just remove this from the
screen so this is murderer Chris Watts
is getting love letters in prison from
women this is a quick uh minute and a
half clip let me just pop this in here
tab okay share audio so you guys should
be able to hear this
and let's play this
his crimes were unspeakable the murders
of his pregnant wife and two little
daughters yet 33 year old Chris Watts is
actually receiving love letters so he
killed his wife and his two daughters
sentenced and now they have examples
here on the screen I don't know if you
guys can see these let me try to make it
a little bit bigger
now they have examples here on the
screen of some of the letters that he's
getting from his female admirers uh
in my heart you're a great guy okay
heart you're a great guy writes a woman
named Candace if you do write me back
I'd be the happiest girl alive that's
for sure she signed off with hashtags
team Chris Chris is innocent love him
and so cute another woman named Tatiana
wrote I found myself thinking a lot
about you is that the photo of herself
in a bikini whoa whoa
I don't know if you can see that here
let me go a bigger screen
this is the chick that's fantasizing for
this guy that was convicted of killing
his wife and his kids this is her right
here
she's attractive just just putting it
out there right like these are not gross
women
a woman named Kim wrote I'm hoping to
brighten your days Hannah wrote Chris
watt's name in Flowery calligraphy and
told him I feel this connection to you I
feel a connection to you dude murdered
his wife and his kids and some random
check out in another part of the world
seeing this either in the media or on TV
feels a connection to it many of the
letters which were released by
prosecutors are signed with hearts and
X's and O's for hugs and kisses these
women have created a fantasy lives for
themselves especially with their pretend
relationship with these Men Behind Bars
psychologist Dr Judy ho co-host of TD's
face the truth says even the worst
killers have groupies who write visit
and even propose marriage it's
oftentimes what we talk about when women
seem to be attracted to Bad Boys it's
because they want to be the special
person that can turn this life around
and then be able to attribute that okay
so we've heard that about three times
now right like turn turn this guy's life
around
own self-esteem Parkland school shooter
Nicholas Cruz Boston Marathon bomber Joe
carzarnaev and white killer Scott
Peterson all received Love Letters From
women now Chris Watts joins that
notorious list okay so this isn't just
the whole Jeffrey Dahmer thing right
like this this is this goes on a lot of
different angles hey guys I really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out